Atomic memory operation have a number of limitations that you need to know about.
First of all, only certain operations and data types are supported.
So there's things like add and subtract, and min and x or, and so forth.
But you can't do every operation. There's no mod, for example. There's no exponentiate.
You can't do every operation. And only certain data types are supported,
in particular, mostly integer types.
So, atomic ad and atomic exchange are the only types that actually support floating point operations.
There's a workaround for this.
It turns out that you can implement any atomic operation
by using the atomic compare and swap operation.
And I'm not going to go into the details. This gets into mutexes and critical sections.
There's a short example in the programming guide that gives you an example
of how to implement, for example, 64 bit operations using atomic CAS.
You need to be aware that there's still is no ordering constraints, right?
So the different threads in a thread block and the different thread blocks themselves
will be running in some unspecified order.
It will be different every time.
So the operations that you're performing on memory using a atomics are
still going to happen in an unspecified order.
This is important, because floating-point arithmetic is actually non-associative.
In other words, the quantity of "a plus b plus c" is not the same as "a plus the quantity of b plus c."
It's real easy to convince yourself if you look at numbers like say, a equals 1,
b equals 10 to the 99th, and c equals 10 to the 99th.
You can just plug this into your c decompiler or your calculator, for that matter,
and you'll discover that you don't get the same number, depending on what order you do these operations in.
And the final thing to be really aware of with atomics is that there's no magic happening under the hood.
The GPU is still forcing each thread to take turns giving access to that memory.
It's serializing the access to memory among the different threads.
And this can make atomic operations very slow, if you're not careful.
Let's look into that.